1 sauf
peut-être la clé de l'innovation
alors pour l'illustrer je vais
petite histoire nous sommes en 2008 je
fais du ski avec ma famille quand je
reçois un coup de téléphone de xavier
fontanet le président le pdg de
d'essilor il me dit voilà j'ai rencontré
le pdg de nikon et nous avons décidé de
créer ensemble un centre de recherche
qui accueillera des chercheurs d'essilor
et des chercheurs d'une icône un centre
de recherche pour travailler sur des
nouveaux matériaux sur le
l'optoélectronique pour inventer les
travailler pour avancer
pardon pour créer les matériaux de
demain
bon jeu donc on accroche et puis là tout
d'un coup je réalise la complexité de ce
que ça représente vous avez d'un côté
essilor leader mondial de l'optique
ophtalmique des verres ophtalmiques avec
des équipes d armes et de chercheurs
français qui travaillent sur des
technologies très pointues
vous avez de l'autre côté nicole l'un
des leaders de la photographie notamment
avec d'une armée de chercheurs avec des
technologies propres avec des chercheurs
japonais au japon et puis on me demande
de mélanger tout ça est de l'inventer
des nouveaux matériaux et de d'innover
moi qui cherchais un nouveau challenge
moi qui voulais me mettre en danger être
être encore une fois dans une logique un
petit peu de nouvelles aventures j'ai
été servi je pense qu'en termes de
complexité
il était difficile de trouver plus plus
compliqué en tout cas avec avec ses 7
cette équation
eh bien figurez vous que ce centre de
recherche a été a vécu pendant pendant a
fonctionné pendant dix ans et a été un
grand succès si je vois certains d'entre
vous qui ont des lunettes sûrement des
lunettes essilor
si vous y réfléchissez elles ont des
fonctions anti salissures anti-buée anti
scratch elles ont des fonctions de
pacification et bien je suis certain que
certaines des technologies de ce centre
de recherche sont incorporées dans ses
dents ses verres de lunettes
si on regarde les caméras qui filment 6e
sont j'en suis pas sûr d des objectifs
nikon je suis certain que si c'en était
il y aurait deux dans une technologie
issue de ceux de ce centre de recherche
donc c'était un grand succès et pourquoi
est-ce que ça a été un grand succès ce
que je
partager avec vous c'est parce que
finalement on aurait pu faire très
complexe on aurait pu mettre en place
des organisations spécifiques on aurait
pu mettre en place des procédures on
aurait pu complexifier ce qui était déjà
compliqué de faire de l'innovation dans
un domaine aussi technologique en
finalement ajoutant maintes et maintes
'reporting' maintes et maintes réunions
et à l'opposé le paradoxe est que
finalement pour cette situation pour ce
centre de recherche très compliqué avec
deux cultures aussi différentes l'une
que l'autre
eh bien nous avons choisi de faire clair
de faire simple et de fait reproche de
jouer la proximité
ces trois mots clarté simplifie et
simplicité et proximité c'est ce que je
voudrais il faudrait illustré par avec
vous tout de suite et c'est là qu'arrive
le divan le sofa pourquoi parce que
finalement ce centre de recherche
c'était une start up
c'était finalement le meilleur le
meilleur des deux mondes le meilleur du
monde de la start up
il fallait tout créé à partir de rien
les laboratoires le règlement le
règlement intérieur trouver un moyen de
faire la comptabilité
recruté au compte gouttes des chercheurs
d'une icône des chercheurs d'essilor des
chercheurs français au japon pour pour
étoffer l'équipe donc on était
complètement dans une logique de start
up et finalement on avait le meilleur du
de l'autre monde du monde des grands
groupes à ce qu'on avait le back up
financier est aussi en réservoir de
personnel de chercheurs on avait ces
deux grands groupes nikon essilor qui va
inquiéter la donc si vous voulez tout
était parfait pour pour finalement que
ce sont de recherche avance et comme on
était en mode start up je me suis dit
nous avions un grand open space je me
suis dit tiens mettons dans un coin un
petit coin détente avec une cafetière
avec un tableau blanc et puis avec le
sofa comme ça peut se faire finalement
dans des entreprises en tant que
français et européens peut-être avec un
esprit occidental je me disais que
c'était finalement l'occasion de faire
une pause discuter ensemble
naïvement parce que qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
les premières semaines était assez assez
laborieuse alors je n'étais pas surpris
parce que j'avais travaillé six ans dans
une entreprise japonaise étant le seul
franc non non japonais dans un centre de
recherche de 1500 personnes en
survêtement bleu ciel en faisant la
gymnastique le matin à 8h30 donc je le
savais je connaissais la difficulté de
choc et d'apporter finalement un choc de
cultures
donc j'étais prêt j'étais prêt à 7 à
cette confrontation cet apprentissage
difficile de la vie ensemble
ce mélange d intelligence j'étais près
j'étais prêt à accepter ça mais je
trouvais que malgré tout ça se passait
mal un des chercheurs français me disais
c'est incroyable comme ça fait du bruit
quand on tape sur un clavier mon voisin
japonais fait vraiment du bruit donc à
un des petits des petits des petits
détails comme ça lorsque vous savez
lorsqu'on fait des réunions au japon la
culture japonaise fait qu'on va en
réunion que quand on a le consensus
vous savez la réunion n'est qu'un moyen
de montrer de partage et de consensus un
français va en réunion vous comprenez
pour justement à paraître dans la
confrontation a donné son avis et
surtout surtout en sort de la réunion
idéalement avec un avis mais surtout on
n'est pas d'accord avant c'est tout
l'enjeu de la discussion et etc c'est
différent cela était de plus en plus
forte
si je prends un autre exemple lorsque
vous fait recette des slides du
powerpoint et que vous êtes japonais eh
bien vous faites un slide vous mettez
tout sur les slides et c'est la personne
qui va regarder de faire son cheminement
sur le slide c'est aussi valable
finalement qu autre chose c'est à la
personne de faire son cheminement vous
êtes français vous pour la même
problématique vous allez faire dit slide
et vous allez en entonnoir arriver à la
solution unique
voilà qui est évidente et qui va marcher
donc voilà c'est par ces deux petits
exemples réunion slide et bien je me
rendais compte que finalement personne
ne faisait l'effort personne tout le
monde se rester sur son sa méthode est
au bout de quelques semaines je dirais
la halle à la sauce ne prenait pas je
m'y attendais mais pas à ce point là et
le canapé le sofa finalement ne jouait
pas son rôle il y avait il ya peu de
pauses café en tout cas les français
prenaient un café ensemble les japonais
ne le faisait pas
donc ça ne marchait pas et puis arrive
la révélation il y aura un miracle après
il m'est arrivé à moi une révélation je
discute avec un chercheur japonais et je
lui dis mais au fait pourquoi est-ce que
vous n'habitez personnes de chez nikon
dans le centre de recherche pourquoi est
ce que on a pas de visite des gens nikon
ils sont nés à tokyo ils sont ils sont à
côté pour qu'est ce qu'ils ne viennent
pas il réfléchit un petit peu il est
comment me le dire il me dit shimon san
en fait c'est à cause du sofa j'sais pas
si vous voyez pourquoi parce que le sofa
sakho des l'inactivité sakho dès le
moment de pause sakho de sakho dès
justement l'opposé du travail et au
japon au japon on travaille d'après la
gymnastique de 8h35
à 22h au japon c'est le pays au monde où
il faut montrer qu'on travaille il faut
être le plus devant son écran il faut le
le plus fortement montrer
qu'on est impliqué lorsque auparavant
ses collègues
les collègues disent en tout cas les
samares c'est à dire oui tu pars tu dois
être bien fatigué pour l'excusé de
partir avant avant avant les autres
pendant cinq ans donc on restaurer ce
travail parce qu'il faut rester au
travail c'est important est à revoir et
moi je mets en plein milieu du sort de
l'open space m'a un sofa qui codent le
non travail et et voilà quoi raté raté
donc je comprends la révélation est là
pour cent bien sûr j'aurais dû le savoir
j'ai finalement moi qui voulait créer
une bonne entente mois dont la
responsabilité d'un patron du centre et
son patron du centre était vain de créer
cette cette fusion évidemment j'avais
j'avais mis en plein milieu une verrue
le finalement l'objet qui était qui
qui devait qui s'incline avec comme
fonction pour les japonais que de les
empêcher finalement d'être à l'aise
et puis le jour de l'inauguration du
centre arrive avec sa vue fontanes et
était présent et monsieur cariat le
patron de nikon arrive en avance et
vient visiter le centre de recherche
et puis ils voulaient regarder à nouveau
son discours il sent son papier et dont
un café et qu'arrive t-il il s'assoit
sur le sofa et bien je peux vous dire
qu'à partir de ce moment là le sofa a
été une révolution le sofa a été l'une
des clés sinon la clé de l'innovation la
clé du succès du centre de recherche
nikon essilor tous les chercheurs de
japonais de nikon se sont sentis
autorisés à asseoir un sens fort sur ce
sofa le patron
naturellement elle avait fait donc ça a
été pour moi un moment clé a été vous
avez compris le miracle à partir de ce
moment là et bien finalement ce qui
s'est passé ça a été encore une fois
assez magique parce que les le problème
des réunions été résolu parce que
finalement on se retrouvait à 5 10 15 20
autour autour du sofa les japonais
avaient l'impression de faire du
consensus à nouveau discuter avec nous
les français étaient là puisqu'on
n'était pas en réunion et les japonais
n'avaient pas conscience de soi mal et
français donner leur avis on était dense
est aussi confrontation française
positive donc finalement la réunion se
faisait ni à la mode japonaise ni à la
mode française autour de ce sofa et on a
avancé comme ça on a résolu des
problèmes voyais pas de slide pourquoi
avoir des slides si on autant du sofa on
écrit sur le tableau blanc nos idées en
avance chacun exprime avec ses mots avec
ses mains en anglais ou avec c'est
surtout avec ses mains le les
problématiques
voilà finalement finalement autour de ce
sofa c'était simple on était proche la
proximité là le mélange encore une fois
c'est intelligent soit ces faits là et
puis finalement la clarté ce qui est ce
que j'ai oublié de vous dire c'est que
finalement la mission de ce centre de
recherches pourraient pouvait paraître
peut-être parfois compliqué à certains
mais le fait de s'asseoir le fait de
deux finalement exprimées par des mots
simples ce qu'on pourquoi on était là
c'est ça ça a donné une sorte de carte
est à nous et à notre mission on a à ce
moment là était une entité on a récement
la cré est vraiment vraiment le centre
de recherche nikon et filant donc encore
une fois clarté simplicité proximité jeu
je le vois à travers un toit toujours à
travers ce sofa et finalement dans
d'autres expériences j'ai essayé de
réfléchir à ce qui ce qui dans mon
parcours a donné lieu à l'utilisation de
oc 3 se montre assez 3 3 mots et je me
suis rendu compte que parfois mais on
pouvait pas tout faire
j'étais le travail et donc auparavant
pour une équivalent de procter & gamble
asiatiques cao cao corporation et en
allemagne
et justement j'ai été responsable de la
recherche appliquée de chaos en
allemagne donc si vous voulez j'étais un
français qui représentait le corporate
japonais en allemagne en parlant donc en
anglais avec les japonais et les
allemands donc des obstacles et jeu en
termes d'organisation là encore on était
dans la complexité et la cette fois ci
on ne pouvait pas simplifier la logique
de simplification n'était pas là parce
que l'organisation était comme celle là
et finalement en jouant sur la clarté en
jouant sur le fait qu'à chaque réunion
et ça c'est très japonais à chaque
réunion
les cinq piliers de l'innovation du
groupe sont sont affichés sont rappelés
l'alignement et effet finalement à
chaque fois contraint et forcé parfois
mais été fait le fait que la proximité
la proximité des équipes mais la
proximité avec le consommateur
le fait que finalement on parle le même
langage entre nous parce qu on
s'appuyait sur les océans sion des
données des données consommateurs clair
à a finalement permis de demain de
finalement de réussir dans dans les
projets d'innovation une feinte de
japonais se lave les cheveux
une fois par jour expliqué à mes
collègues japonais qu'une femme
allemande ou française va se laver les
cheveux
une fois tous les deux jours une fois
tout une fois tous les trois jours ça
peut paraître finalement anodin mais
mais vous imaginez que dans la
cosmétique ça d impact incroyable sur la
formulation et partager cette
connaissance la partager cette
information c'est un exemple que je
donne finalement permettait à dresde
valade resserrer les liens dans l'équipe
et de travailler sur sur dû encore une
fois des données du factuel dans une
autre expérience là on est dans le
groupe seb
cette fois ci en termes d'organisation
et on en a eu là le souhait de
simplifier l'organisation en tout cas
sur certains projets très spécifique
d'innovation et on a créé donc on a créé
un semblable donc on prend les mots les
mots clés fablab do it yourself design
thinking makers
on mélange tout et on crée donc un une
entité un laboratoire qui en façon très
rapide
encore une fois dans une logique de
hacking permis et permet de
on l'a vu aussi tout à l'heure de halle
est allé plus vite d'aller plus vite et
de fédérer des équipes la grande
simplicité de ce qui est de ce fait
apporter se soucier blog ça a été de 2 a
ajouté la proximité dans les équipes et
pour conclure ce que je peux partager
avec vous c'est que finalement qu'on
soit dans le domaine de l'entreprise
d'action politique finalement partout eh
bien on peut toujours avoir son petit
sofa avec soin on peut toujours se dire
comment commandant monde dans mon projet
dans mon mon objectif comment est ce que
je peux apporter plus de clarté pour les
équipes pour le pour le dirigeant pour
pour ma communication comment est ce que
je peux être plus simple dans dans dans
les modes de fonctionnement dans
l'organisation on n'est jamais assez
simple et de la même manière on n'est
jamais assez proche donc encore une fois
mon jeu je vous invite à faire preuve
d'encore davantage de clarté et de
simplicité et proximité
merci
[Applaudissements]